[Aplausos]
na hora todos nós estamos aqui é uma
chamada dos mesmos às três da manhã do
dia 2 de abril
contávamos ademir foi só no dia seguinte
o cliente que eles tinham no final
como é uma idéia tão simples nos trazem
as duas usinas fazemos carros juntos e
estamos constantemente a pena ler isto
marca coisa dentro do fato para depois
tudo isso outras com essa situação e nós
vamos dizer alguma coisa eu disse sou um
deles se e quando a senhora de 80 anos
não tiver feito alguma coisa do nosso
planeta então acho que não vai ter briga
pelo reconhecimento que a conversa se
tornaram mais frequentes esse excelente
queremos ter um impacto significativo
que qualquer um se juntar a nós que
fazer a diferença
responsáveis pela coisa tão simples como
eu vai transferir as clássicas canções
de cássia e porque permite só o futebol
francês unb é o que tem mais quatro
porém o que se observa nas cinco voltas
ao planeta terra foi 57 anos que está
aberto também um convite pessoal estava
marcado nossa constante em experiências
além de ser posta não só vez cinco anos
juntas por mais uma amiga criar um
movimento claro que os fatos e fiquei
cascade caixa porque eu sei que nós
mesmos não seremos bem definido o maior
número de apoiantes preto nosso
movimento provocando pânico seria que
tivéssemos nós só nos principais
restaurantes e hotéis em março já será
um grande passo
vamos à procura de alternativas
economicamente e ambientalmente mais
sustentáveis procurados da organização
muito convencido que vamos bater à porta
dos restaurantes perceber caia cria
deixar de servir com a linha sport e
apenas servir uma palhinha tratando
conheço esse movimento já queremos ter
pelo menos cinco restaurantes ambiente
para nossa surpresa sempre mais uma
história assim manteremos a porta que
esperamos novos incinde muito enviaram
o projeto nosso lado contávamos um
autocolante com o nosso voto na porta do
estabelecimento e publicá los adiante em
nosso site e fetiche anos também
tentaram deter o embaixador de
identificação com a causa e também
fazendo que os pais e rapidamente
passaram a contar com a epe o frágil do
que desejam os seus irmãos voluntários
de amarante balas e hotéis que aderiram
ao movimento
ainda há pessoas que só consegue mudar o
estilo de vida que ela vai fazer e como
seria mais claro até agora vamos passar
de todo o plástico descartável xiv
semente de ter trechos de música que
deixaram a resposta que ele ama em tão
pouco tempo uma tábua toma proporções
que claramente se trava no aspecto
fiscal porque estava a precisar de uma
maioria muito grande pelo estudo dos
fósseis em cascais mas movimento começa
o primeiro passo claramente a vontade de
provar os fundos agora nós estamos muito
contentes em ter as pessoas querem levar
o nosso movimento disse que as caixas
para outros lados e vai incidir delas
mora em breve vamos ter um movimento
claro ele séria entre a madeira e lisboa
não está com esta apresentação não é só
nós estamos a fazer mas o canal você
também pode fazer alguma coisa se
preocupar com alguma coisa se inquieta
querem falar alguma coisa então faça não
precisa ter com sal junto de 72 9 a 15
paixão de conselhos e começa a cantar
para vocês e não importando produtos
entre habitantes ficaram em alguns
pontos
as cozinhas não mas pela
consciencialização ambiental estiveram
nesta programa aqui uma telinha após
causar então muito provavelmente não
pensaram duas vezes e só plástico no
supermercado sakashita 700 nós temos
teve que improvisar uma esmola não
tentar um dia inteiro escreveu em dar
voz à comunidade
se você quer fazer um impacto na nossa
escola pouco então é muito provável que
outras pessoas gente viria a se entender
fazer diferença delas morrem 2 5 me
preocupar com coisas realmente
importantes que possam ter um impacto
positivo na nossa senhora
trabalhei que junta da pessoa com as
mesmas paixões depois nos a obra dos
cabeças pensam melhor do que uma e
brilha até ficar sempre mais motivação
vamos construir a combinar com nós
queremos viver agora já sabe pé são
sempre as vossas vidas em perigo se
quiseram juntar a nós temos gente a
vontade da nossa equipa
até agora já conseguimos evitar 30 mil
bolinhas de fran e queremos continuar a
aumentar os juros
como é que tivemos um pneu nós
precisamos dessa manhã escreveu de uma
casa eu não consigo esperar até a manhã
seguinte perceber como sempre ajudava a
brigada
[Música]